the best way to learn more about the
University Center is to go
floor-by-floor flood start from the top
on the third floor you'll find the
offices of our student organizations
down on the second floor you can find
dining facilities ranging from sushi to
sandwiches we also have vegan vegetarian
and kosher options as well also on the
second floor you can find a lot of our
workout facilities we have a
weightlifting room an aerobic room and a
group exercise room in addition to
squash and racquetball courts on the
first floor you can find more workout
facilities you have more squash and
racquetball courts in addition to a
basketball court and a half size Olympic
swimming pool also on the first floor
you can find our student grocery store
called entropy inside we have fresh
produce easy Mac and of course Red Bull
on the first floor you can also find our
bookstore and group areas such as this
one here down in the basement we have
many things the Career Center bookstore
art store post office FedEx in the bank
clearly you can see while you'll be in
the University Center at least once per
day founded in 1937 scotch and soda
theater is one of the nation's oldest
completely student-run non major theater
groups they perform five to seven shows
each academic year in a variety of
locations throughout the university and
throughout their history they've been a
venue for the performance of original
student written works the most famous of
which being Pippin which was written by
a Drama alum Stephen Schwartz five years
before it was performed on Broadway with
director Bob Fosse it had its world
premiere in 1967 with scotch and soda
theater